three weeks ago i went to my doctor and
my thyroid levels are still out of whack
and my dermatologist wanted to put me on
stronger medication for my eczema and so
i decided that i would take some time to
challenge myself to make a huge change
so i have decided to try the keto diet
for one entire month and so basically
for the last three weeks what i have
done is i have cut out all sugar
completely and avoiding carbs that means
no breads grains legumes or even starchy
vegetables my challenge to myself also
includes strict intermittent fasting
where i'm fasting every single day for
at least 16 to 18 hours and i'm also
including at least one 24-hour fast
weekly it has only been three weeks but
i am super excited to share my results
with you because i am shook but because
it's only been three weeks that video is
to come i will share the before and
afters and all the effects that i have
experienced throughout the one month
period so that one is to come but for
now i really wanted to share with you
why i decided to try the keto diet what
i'm eating what i've done to cope with
some of the difficulties of the keto
diet and especially that dreaded keto
flu and i also wanted to share this
because i have ruffled some people's
feathers
some time ago i shared with you why i no
longer eat a vegan diet and it upsets
some people and it's understandable but
at the same time i have to do what is
best for my body and i also know that it
left some people wondering so
what are you eating now and so today i
wanted to share with you what i'm eating
what i'm not eating how i avoided that
dreaded keto flu all together and why
i'm currently loving the keto diet so
far
so
why keto i was having some uncomfortable
side effects because of hashimoto's
hyperthyroidism and my eczema was just
out of control no matter what natural
remedies i tried and as i learned about
the recommended anti-inflammatory diet
for hashimoto's i became very interested
in learning about inflammation and
specifically what i can do to reduce
inflammation and even though my
rheumatologist pcp and endocrinologist
all seemed to agree that there was
nothing that i could do about this
condition and i would eventually end up
on medication for the rest of my life i
couldn't quite help but think if there's
something that i can do to help even
just a little bit then i owe it to
myself to try it i had read about
studies regarding the keto diet helping
to reduce seizure activity in patients
with epilepsy but i had never really
dove any deeper than that until i came
across dr berg and he really sparked my
curiosity when he presented a quote from
the book medical physiology stating all
aspects of fat metabolism are greatly
enhanced in the absence of insulin
basically to simplify it the more sugary
and carb-loaded my meals are the more i
cause my insulin to spike then worse off
my metabolism and the more i trigger
inflammation which is really the root
cause of most diseases anyway so even
when i had the vegan diet and i was
eating tons of veggies which was great i
was unknowingly still spiking my insulin
levels by eating things that were loaded
with carbs and sugars carbs turn into
sugars later anyway when we eat carbs
they turn into sugar in the body which
causes insulin to spike but when we
reduce the amount of carbs that we eat
we therefore lower our sugar and lower
our insulin which makes your body turn
to burning fat instead of sugar for
energy and so this has been the
determining factor in deciding which
foods i eat and which foods i do not eat
all right so what am i eating my main
focus when it comes to choosing what i'm
eating on the keto diet is to make sure
that my meals are as jam-packed with
nutrients as much as possible because
since i am intermittent fasting and i'm
already on a restricted diet anyway i
want to make sure that all of my meals
are loaded with veggies and really focus
on nourishing my body so i make sure to
eat lots of greens and especially
nutrient rich greens so basically kale
over lettuce for example and more
benefits of loading up on veggies is
that they're high in fiber and they can
improve your digestive flora which does
wonders for your body when it comes to
the meat department it's also really
important to choose good quality
proteins so organic grass-fed meats
thankfully we have chickens outside
which you can probably hear in the
background so i have a great supply of
organic eggs but i also still really
enjoy my favorite vegan pea protein
powder by sun warrior because it's keto
friendly no soy or whey and it's a
really high quality pea protein plus
it's super delicious with no chalky
aftertaste for fats i like to follow dr
burke's advice most of the time and that
is to make sure that your proteins are
included together with your fats so
basically that means something like a
crunchy bacon a fatty salmon an egg with
the yolk but i also really love avocados
so i enjoy the heck out of those bad
boys i usually have two meals per day
and i allow myself one sweet tasting
snack somewhere in between and it's
usually either of these two things a
coffee latte with some unsweetened pea
milk unflavored collagen powder coconut
creamer or coconut milk and a packet of
sweetener
check out this latte art you guys
i could be a barista
gorgeous
or my next favorite which is a delicious
berry smoothie i add just a little bit
of raspberries which is the only fruit
that i am allowing myself because it's
very low in neck carbs a tablespoon of
flax seeds
unflavored collagen
and of course my favorite pea protein
powder in the flavor berry by a sun
warrior no stevia or any kind of
sweetener needed for this one because
it's already sweet enough i love this i
actually have tried some of the like
alternative keto recipes to carb things
i recently made a flat bread out of
coconut flour and psyllium husk powder
which was actually pretty good but i
haven't really made them since then
because the way i see it is this i am
eating during a short window and i'm
already restricting myself to the things
that i eat so i want to make sure that i
nourish my body as much as possible and
so if i get full on coconut flour then i
think that kind of defeats the purpose
at least for me anyway but it is nice to
know that you also have these other
options so that you're not feeling like
you can't have anything or if you have a
craving then there are alternatives that
you can have i know that some people use
fat bombs which are basically like a fat
loaded snack or a drink to try to reduce
hunger so that it makes it more
manageable as they transition into the
keto diet but i personally don't really
recommend doing it for an extended
period of time if what you're trying to
do is doing it for weight loss because
coming from somebody that has done
intermittent fasting for a long period
of time i mean years on and off i've
just i've come to learn that hunger is
something that doesn't just accumulate
and get worse over time that really it
comes and goes in waves because of
hormones it's a hormonal process and so
as you learn to kind of manage that and
maneuver that it becomes more manageable
and then food becomes something that's
pleasing that's meant to nourish your
body as opposed to just kind of an
addiction or eating out of plain boredom
or eating out of emotion because i was
definitely an emotional eater in the
past let me know am i the only one have
you ever overeaten because of an emotion
you were feeling let's talk about that
dreaded keto flu i feel like everybody
talks about this but i felt like i
developed a pretty good grasp for it
when i tried a 48-hour water only fast
by putting my body under unnecessary
torture i learned a few things that
helped me to avoid the keto flu
altogether in these last three weeks so
keep these things in mind and hopefully
they will help you the first thing is
that if you pair keto with intermittent
fasting because of the boosted effects
on your metabolism don't just drink
water for hydration drink green tea or
matcha which is loaded with antioxidants
vitamins and minerals and electrolytes
if you're feeling hungry grab yourself
one of these first also for the first
week or so i was urinating a lot i mean
i was urinating like i was nine months
pregnant you guys and so i did some
research on it because i thought this
was weird and i came to realize that
it's actually common as your body starts
to transition into fat burning mode and
so to avoid dehydration i have been
adding a lot of salt to my meals and
actually this is something that was to
me pretty exciting because i always
avoided salt thinking that i was doing
the healthy option but i think that this
has definitely helped me to avoid those
dehydration symptoms and the headaches
and just those symptoms in general and
i've also been very diligent to take my
supplements seriously because again this
is not about hurting my body to achieve
a certain goal it's about nourishing my
body and giving it sort of a reset
period so i really like to add
nutritional use to really most anything
like my sauteed veggies or scrambled
eggs because it's a good source of
vitamin b i'm also taking a multivitamin
a vitamin d3 omegas and a good quality
probiotic the one that i use is by mega
food and it's called mega flora i am no
doctor to recommend this to you but
there is a huge link between your gut
health and your body's overall health
and so i've spent hours and hours trying
to find the right probiotic because a
lot of them are so expensive they have
such a high price tag but yet they have
all these strains that are really
actually not doing your body any good
and so i tried to find a good compromise
for me that was an okay prize that also
had some strains that would be helpful
for my body i am really trying to heal
my body inside out and so personally i
view it as an important part of my daily
routine so now let's talk about what i'm
not eating because i can see where this
can kind of get counterproductive and
keep in mind that this is just what is
working for me the first thing that i
want to mention is dairy because a lot
of people really enjoy adding cheese and
creams and all these things on their
keto diet but for me i have found that
all those sorts of things are just
highly inflammatory they flare up my
eczema they make me bloated and have
other gi side effects and so yeah no no
milk and cheese and all those things for
me no thank you i do eat my organic eggs
as i mentioned but as far as like milk
and cheese and those sorts of things
it's plant-based so basically like
unsweetened female almond milk or
coconut milk which is high in fat so
it's perfect for keto anyway i also am
avoiding gmos soy because of its effects
on estrogen and most of it is gmo anyway
and whey because away tends to spike
insulin and remember the goal is to keep
that insulin down i'm also personally
avoiding all those prepackaged keto
snacks like the keto cookies and cereals
and whatever else is out there because
again my focus is nourishing my body and
so even if it means i have to cook a
little bit more i don't think it really
necessarily means that i have to spend a
lot of time with it because i could just
have a salad that has avocado or boiled
eggs and there you go i can just do that
really quickly and i don't really need
the prepackaged snacks so i don't need
you keto cookies and when it comes to
meats i eat meats with no nitrates
preservatives or sugars added because
the first time i was really going
looking for meats for keto i realized
that there are a lot of meats that have
sugars in them which you'd be surprised
so read the labels on them because
they're sneaky and it's also important
to know that when it comes to those zero
calorie sweeteners they're not all the
same i was about to purchase a stevia
that in the ingredients list had
dextrose well dextrose increases your
insulin levels and so that kind of
defeats the purpose i personally use
erythritol it just happens to be what i
found at my grocery store it's of course
not as good as the real deal but it'll
do when i want the occasional coffee
latte and last but not least why am i
loving it so far oh i really don't want
to give it all away because i'm going to
be filming a full video on all those
details later on but i'm really excited
that i have taken this as seriously as i
have because
for the first time in a long time i have
a flat belly with no bloating and my
skin i'm just really excited to show you
the before and after pictures and i've
had a lot of other side effects as well
that i'm really excited to share with
you so if you're interested in that make
sure you hit that subscribe button and
the notification bell so that you won't
miss when it's out or miss any of my
other videos i hope that you found this
video helpful i thank you so much for
watching and i can't wait to hear from
you in the comments until next time bye